the head of the fda tells cbs news there
is no political pressure
to fast-track a coronavirus vaccine
before the election
without fully testing it but
commissioner stephen hahn says he may
consider an emergency use authorization
for vaccine before clinical trials are
finished dr hahn spoke with our chief
medical correspondent that's dr
john lepuc good morning to you doc dr
lepux so
here's a question i know your name why
are some doctors very alarmed by this
potential move
well good morning gail dr hahn was
already facing criticism over his
agency's decision
to grant emergency use authorization for
hydroxychloroquine which was later
rescinded
and convalescent plasma as you may
remember both treatments were heavily
promoted by
the president now dr han's latest
comments have renewed concerns that his
agency is being politicized
something he flatly denies
our decision at fda will not be made
on any other criteria than the science
and data
associated with these clinical trials
fda commissioner dr stephen hahn vowed
not to let politics interfere with the
approval process
for a coronavirus vaccine at any point
in the pandemic have you felt
pressured politically to make a decision
one way or another
i have not been pressured politically to
make
an incorrect decision how about pressure
to make what you think is a correct
decision so we have felt i mean
there's been pressure throughout this
pandemic i think anybody who doesn't
acknowledge that
would be kidding themselves there's been
pressure to make sure that we get
medical products
as quickly as possible to the american
people leading experts like dr anthony
fauci have said they're cautiously
optimistic
a safe and viable vaccine could be
available by the end of the year
but earlier this month president donald
trump offered an even shorter timeline
suggesting a vaccine could be ready
around election day
it wouldn't hurt but i'm not doing that
i'm doing it not for the election
i want it fast because i want to save a
lot of lives
dr hahn says the fda could reach that
target under an emergency use
authorization program
before a phase 3 trial is completely
finished
but there are concerns rushing a vaccine
could compromise its safety
and exacerbate the fears of those who
already don't trust
vaccines over the weekend parents
gathered outside the massachusetts state
house in boston
to protest a new flu vaccine mandate for
all school children
forcing us to inject something into our
child that we don't agree with
as you know there are concerns about the
risks of going at warp speed
do you think an emergency use
authorization might increase those
concerns
so i think again this will have to be
driven by those science and data
we've been very clear about what we
expect to see
in the data that come to us
when i asked dr han about the emergency
use authorization for hydroxychloroquine
being rescinded
he compared the process to a doctor
making decisions in the emergency room
after the patient's admitted to the
hospital as more information emerges
those decisions can be revised tony
very interesting we do want the science
not the politics to lead john lepuc for
us john thank you very much